Nos piden que resolvamos la ecuación
-3x cuadrada más 10x menos 3 igual a 0.
Y hay varias formas de resolver esto,
sin embargo yo quiero resolverlo
y centrarme en encontrar las raíces
por medio de la fórmula cuadrática,
así que déjame escribirla aquí otra vez
-3x cuadrada más 10x menos 3 igual a 0,
y date cuenta que ya está en su forma estándar,
y quiero resolver esta ecuación 2 veces,
para que te des cuenta
que usando la fórmula cuadrática,
no importa como manipulemos esta ecuación,
nos van a dar las mismas raíces,
los mismos resultados.
Y bueno,
ya que tenemos aquí la ecuación
¿Cuánto vale "a", "b" y "c"?
Y para esto sería muy bueno recordar
que es lo que nos dice la fórmula cuadrática,
y la fórmula cuadrática
nos dice lo siguiente,
si tenemos ecuaciones
de la forma estándar
ax cuadrada más bx más "c" igual a 0,
entonces las raíces de esta ecuación
son igual a -"b"
más menos la raíz cuadrada
de "b" cuadrada menos 4ac,
todo esto sobre 2a,
y aquí está la fórmula cuadrática
que hemos derivado de
esta ecuación cuadrática que tenemos aquí.
Lo cual lo hemos visto
en varios videos pasados,
y hablando de, recuerda que la fórmula cuadrática tiene 2 posibles soluciones,
una tomando el signo positivo
y otra tomando el signo negativo,
pero bueno regresemos a esta ecuación.
¿Cuánto vale "a", "b" y "c"?
Como ya está en forma estándar,
sabemos que "a" vale igual a -3,
"b" va a valer igual a 10
y "c", va a valer -3
y bueno una vez que ya tenemos
"a", "b" y "c",
entonces podemos solucionar esta ecuación cuadrática utilizando la fórmula cuadrática,
que dice -"b," es decir -10,
más menos la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada
pero "b" vale 10,
10 al cuadrado es 100,
menos 4 veces ac
-4 por -3 por -3,
mejor déjenme escribirlo
para que quede todo bastante claro.
Me va a quedar
-4 por -3 por -3,
la raíz cuadrada de todo esto
y después
a todo lo que tenemos aquí arriba,
hay que dividirlo entre 2 veces "a"
que es 2 por -3 es -6.
Entonces ¿Qué me queda?
-10 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 100
menos y aquí tengo -3, por -3, lo cual me da 9 positivo,
9 positivo por 4 es 36
y este menos se queda en menos,
-36
y todo esto dividido
entre -6
y 100 menos 36 es 64
por lo tanto,
me queda -10
más menos la raíz cuadrada de 64 entre -6
pero 64 tiene raíz cuadrada exacta,
su raíz principal es 8
y si aquí tomo más menos me
queda -10 más -8 entre - 6
y entonces esto es lo que vale "x" y esto me da pie,
a que yo pueda escribir mis 2 raíces.
Mi primera versión de estas raíces es tomando
el signo positivo y me queda -10 más 8,
que es -2 entre -6,
esto cuando tomamos el signo positivo
y es igual a 1/3
menos entre menos me da más
y 2/6 es 1/3
y después si tomamos la versión negativa,
entonces me queda que
"x" es igual a -10 menos 8
lo cual me da -18 entre - 6
y esto es igual a 3 positivo,
menos entre menos me da más,
18 entre 6 me da 3.
Esta es mi segunda raíz,
cuando tomo el signo negativo
y entonces estoy diciendo
que las raíces son 1/3 y 3
de esta ecuación cuadrática
con la que empezamos.
Ahora lo que quiero
que veamos a continuación,
es como si manipulamos esta ecuación cuadrática, vamos a llegar a las mismas raíces,
por que hay personas que podrían pasar
todo esto del otro lado de la ecuación,
o dicho de otra manera,
cambiarle de signo a todo
lo que está en esta ecuación,
y decir que no vamos a llegar a lo mismo.
Así que vamos a hacerlo, me quedaría
3x cuadrada menos 10x más 3 igual a 0.
Lo único que estoy haciendo
es multiplicando todo por -1
y entonces en esta ocasión,
me queda que "a" vale 3,
"b" vale -10
y "c" vale 3
y pues vamos a aplicar otra vez
la fórmula general para ver
si llegamos a las mismas raíces.
Y me queda 10 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de -10 al cuadrado
pero esto es, 100
-10 al cuadrado es 100,
-4 por 3 que es 12,
por 3 que es 36,
12 por 3 es 36
y todo esto dividido
entre 2 veces "a", es decir 6
¿Y cuánto es esto?
Me quedaría 10 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 64 otra vez,
100 menos 36 es lo mismo que 64,
por lo tanto, la raíz es 8
y esto dividido entre 6,
y vamos a calcular las raíces otra vez.
10 más 8 entre 6
es lo mismo que 3,
ó en su dado caso 10 -8 entre 6
es lo mismo que 2/6,
que por cierto habíamos visto que
es lo mismo que 1/3 y aquí está.
Llegamos a lo mismo,
es decir,
que obtenemos las mismas raíces
cuando manipulamos la ecuación.